now that we have all the pieces in place
we'd like to apply the momentum
principle to the rocket problem recall
that the momentum principle is that the
external force on the rocket causes on
the system causes the momentum of the
system to change and the front the
mental definition of a derivative is to
look at the change in momentum between
some times T plus delta T are two states
that we've identified divided by delta T
now recall that we had the momentum of
the system at time T was the mass of the
rocket times V bar over the rocket at
teeth I'll just quickly show mass of the
rocket PR T and we had the system at a t
plus delta T where we had Delta F you'll
equals minus Delta and rocket here we
had M R plus Delta M and we had the
velocity in the ground frame which we
saw was equal to so let's write out the
momentum of the system at time T plus
delta T that was a little bit longer P
system at t plus delta t had two pieces
it had M R plus Delta M R times V of R
of T plus delta T and we were
subtracting now because we made this
change that's minus 10 Delta M R U plus
V of R of T plus delta T and this recall
was the velocity of the fuel now in
position to apply our momentum principle
because we have expressions for the
momentum of the system at time T and at
time T and at time T plus delta T so now
this will be a big expression so we'll
write
force is the limit as delta T goes to
zero now here our first term is n move
our post Delta M R times the velocity of
the rocket at time T plus delta T and
now we have the fuel term minus Delta M
R times u plus V of R of T plus delta T
and we have to subtract from that and
I'll put that indicate that with a
slightly different color mr v of r of t
and the whole thing we're dividing by
delta T now let's look at this
expression first because there's some
very nice simplifications the first
thing we can see let's look at this term
Delta I'm R times V of R notice we have
minus delta mr v of r here so those two
terms cancel and we're just left with
three other terms and let's write them
out so now we have the limit as delta T
goes to 0 and I'm going to combine terms
in the following way mr times B of R of
T plus delta T and over here I have mr
minus B of ours so I have a minus B of R
of T divided by delta T and now I have
one more term here and I'm going to
write this as minus the limit as delta T
goes to 0 of Delta mr over delta T
remember this term cancel we only have u
throughout the speed of the fuel
relative to the rocket and in both cases
this is our first term and here's our
second term let's look at these limits
notice in here we're just taking V of R
of T plus Delta t minus V over R of T
divided by delta T and that's precisely
the definition of the derivative of the
velocity of the rocket so this first
term
our expression becomes the external
force is equal to the mass of our system
times V of R the velocity derivative of
velocity of the rocket and the second
term this is the rate that the fuel is
changing in the rocket the mass this is
rather the rate that the mass of the
rocket is changing so that's the
derivative DMR DT times the relative
velocity of the fuel with respect to the
rocket so this equation here I'll box it
off is called the rocket equation which
we've derived from the momentum
principle using our momentum diagrams
and you can see that this is what people
refer to as rocket science